i really want to start with a sincere
thank you i don't think people are going
to realize how much time and energy
you've put in the last few years to
bring this to life and as a long time
beatles fan the footage is incredible
and i just want to thank you for doing
it
well thank you very very much and can i
also thank michael lindsey hogg for
shooting it because he doesn't get
enough cred because everyone you know
goes you know complains to him about let
it be and all that sort of stuff which
wasn't his fault but he shot this most
unbelievable footage in 1969 and he he
deserves a massive amount more credit
than he gets so
good job done we've both done our
credits
i think a lot of people like a lot of
people are going to focus on the visuals
and they're incredible and what your
team has done but i think what's also
incredible is the audio because a lot of
this stuff was recorded on inaugura
mono
not a lot of dimension to it and your
team have to go in there and like sort
of find
you know pull the magic out can you sort
of talk about the challenges of
of using the audio from the time
well it's a difference between recording
or performing in a recording studio
we're not and even in a studio they
don't roll the tapes all the time you
know but you know so but when they're
going to do something the eight track
rolls
and and yet a lot of this is rehearsing
it's there's a bit it's a difference
between okay let's try and record
something but let's let's just rehearse
so when they're rehearsing the film
through are filming them and and that's
great that's again that you know that's
that's where michael needs to think
because there's not normally a film crew
filming them with rehearsing so this is
one there's a rare time when they
actually actually have a film crew there
and they're being filmed rehearsing but
of course the film crew are only armed
with a mono quarter inch naga machine so
that's what they're recording the sound
on
so you know most of it i would say
probably uh three quarters more than
that probably probably um
seventy percent of the audio is mono
niagara because it's just recording you
know and then when we get to several
rogue then john's hits the record button
on the eight track um from time to time
you know and that and and we can only
have access to those eight tracks which
is always a joy um so what we had to do
is to
try to make these quarter inch mono
sound
better and the other aspect of that of
course is that because it's just a film
crew with a microphone
nobody's on a mixing desk balancing the
guitars and the vocals that's not you
know because that's not really what the
filming is about it's just you know it
is rough rehearsal footage but of course
you know you don't want to listen to
hours of this horrible
unbalance you know the vocals are
drowned out by the guitar that's all
that's the worst possible way that any
band would ever want to be heard and and
and also it's really irritating to
if anyone's listening to the get back
bootlegs like i have for 50 for 40 years
it's like
they're great for a while and then they
become very difficult to listen to and
that's no different so
um you know so what we did is to
investigate a technology that that's
been talked about called d mixing which
is you take a mono track of a you know a
performance and you can split all the
instruments in a machine learning ai way
so we looked at that and we tried some
videos and i i i i thought it was a
thing because i read about it that we
couldn't find any machine learning that
kind of worked well you know it sort of
worked but it was it was bad so we had
um some very clever people down here in
new zealand parkway we said to them can
you actually write and develop this
machine learning take the machine
learning idea and actually make it work
so they came up with a system that works
great
amazing and that was a huge breakthrough
for us and because because one we could
you know just take a performance and and
we could you know have the vocals only
and and when i say vocals only i mean
vocals only ringo's slamming the drums
and you don't hear it don't hear a thing
you don't hear the guitars you just hear
this so we could already you know the
bass we could take off the guitars or
drums and then so we could actually mix
the songs but the real the really good
thing is that
they're often having conversations with
each other and you know our story of the
sessions is told through obviously
through the conversation i mean songs
isn't going to tell the story that's
that's nice but the ups and downs and
the things that go wrong and how they
deal with it is all obviously you learn
about that through their own
conversations from 1969 so a lot of that
talking was tend to be drowned out by
and i think deliberately i think the
beatles were aware that michael lindsay
hogg was recording all this stuff and
that sort of started to irritate them
and they put countermeasures in place so
when they were going to have a talk john
or george would wind up their amp and
one of them would just be strumming the
guitar just just aimlessly no thing
and so there and so michael wasn't going
to get there they sort of they were
fighting this battle and then michael
started to hide mike's everywhere uh so
it was
a weird sort of battle going on between
them but anyway there's all this audio
that is you know all the dialogue is
has guitars all over it but of course
machine learning we take the guitars
away and now we can hear the hear what
they're talking about so that was a huge
breakthrough because ultimately this is
a story and i wanted them
i wanted to listen to what they were
talking about and follow the story and
so we were suddenly cleaned up all this
dialogue and it was a huge breakthrough
for us to be able to
to let them tell their own story through
this time
yeah watching the footage it's like
transporting yourself back in time and
being in the room with them i i cannot
recommend this enough um so you
originally were thinking about doing a
two two and a half hour um
film that was going to be released in
theaters and then obviously covid and
it's a much longer cut do you have a
version for a more casual fan like a two
two and a half hour version of the movie
that like you're happy with that if
you're not like a
so it's just you know what i mean well
we we i mean we were heading in that
direction and i think it was we were
supposed to release you'll probably know
that i think september last year or
something was our release date so you
know come
february march you know jabez my editor
and i think we had something about eight
hours long at that stage and you know we
were heading towards a september thing
it was going to be two and a half hours
by september a few months ago
but i was feeling uncomfortable because
i i should have done this at the
beginning i started to work out the
maths because i'm telling a story over
22 days i've got the rooftop at the end
that's 45 minutes so two and a half
hours take the 45 minutes away each day
by day the thing i i figured out god
that only leaves me like two and a half
minutes per day per day and i wanted you
know each to go to day by day to put it
i can't do this two and a half minutes a
day well what the hell was i thinking
it's impossible and then the pandemic
struck
and and it was disney said oh i think
we're going to delay the whole thing
a year so now we'll do september 2021 i
was like oh really okay great and we was
just going fantastic so we didn't talk
to apple or the beatles they all thought
we were doing two and a half hours and
james and i just spent a year doing the
pandemic making the movie that we wanted
to make so these days but you know we
we said well we need to tell the story
so the days became 15 minutes long 20
minutes long um some of them are 30
minutes long but they do the job and
they've got and so we ended up with
something that was like six hours long
and
and that was like you know we
it was i i
nobody on earth could take that down to
two and a half hours and leave it sort
of
making sense i mean they could but it
would be awful
so we showed it to the beatles early
this year and said look we're sorry
about the two and a half hour thing but
we think this is how it should be told
they looked at it said great don't
change a thing and then and then all
that you know the whole thing went
around the world at six hours now
but what people a lot of people don't
know because we sort of decided to not
not appetite too much and james and i
kept editing and now it's eight hours as
well hey what the hell it's it's still
three parts it's just instead of being
two hours long each part's like two
hours thirty two hours twenty two hours
forty what you know you know it sort of
adds up to near eight hours it's
certainly a long way from six hours but
but that but that's because that we you
know we had we just used the time we had
and we got that's where we think it best
tells the story has all the great stuff
in it as a beatles fan every time i saw
something that is a fan i thought wow
this is great i had a choice i had a
choice to say but we don't really need
it in the movie but it's so good so if
it goes back if we don't put it in the
movie it could disappear in the vault
for another 50 years
but it's so good i want to the middle
fans have got to see this god it's great
so anything that i thought like it's all
gone in the film i i honestly haven't
held anything back that i thought was
really cool as a fan yeah
that's the thing is that i know that the
final running time is very close to
eight hours did you ever
have like a ten hour version or a nine
hour version is there you know because
you you you've definitely released
extended cuts of some of your movies and
i'm just curious it's like i mean i
can't wait to watch all eight hours but
you know is there a longer version even
of what there is yeah yeah i mean we had
you know we started out just think of
the 20 22 day thing which is what
michael was filming you know each day
the niagara machines are you know the
tape machines are sort of rolling for
most of the day
um because quarter inch tape is quite
cheap so the two naga recorders the film
crew had
you know is usually each day is about
between six and eight hours of audio so
most of the time the audio you know the
full day has been recorded and then
during the day as the tape machines are
rolling the cameras are sort of 16
millimeters a lot more expensive so
they're obviously a bit more careful
with that so the cameras have turned on
and off at random times you know two
cameras different times shift positions
you know the audio's going so you've got
about usually three to four hours of
picture of film you know and it
obviously matches the audio but then
you've got all this audio with no
picture so
each day is like that and um
and so what we started out doing because
we had to sort of somehow get this huge
bulk of material under some control
so the first thing we decided to do is
we'll just take it day by day we won't
worry about the length we'll just look
through the the the eight hours of audio
the four hours we'll just edit it we'll
put everything in and so it makes sense
because obviously the audio's gonna you
know there's a lot of black
there's a lot where there's no picture
because if you've got eight hours of
tape and you've got four three or four
hours of film you've got a lot of of
audio with no picture so that's but some
of it's got things you want to use so
you use that audio then you've got to
want to find a bit of picture to put on
it so if there's a conversation there's
no picture we have to find a shot of the
from the back of the room or the beatles
stalking that we could just put yes you
don't really want black to go black
so it was a bit of a job but we thought
let's get the each day just done don't
worry about the link to what it sort of
tells the story and it uses it all to
its maximum effect and we did that and
it turned out to be 18 hours long so
that so yeah we do that was our first we
we sort of got it down to it so
everything had a picture there was no
audio only we had all the audio in there
we wanted it and you know we had it sort
of tidied up and it was 18 hours and
from that point it's really a case of
just you you just make decisions and
nibble things down you know and so we
sort of i think i look there might be
something that's 10 or 12 hours but i
sort of went from 18
and we sort of worked on it got it down
to six and then it's gone back up to
eight again that's sort of what we have
i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
again thank you so much for making this
i really cannot wait to watch the whole
thing
have a fantastic day
you